rapp a déjà gelé 30 milliards d'avoirs
russe plus d'un mois après le début de
la guerre elle dénonce une attaque
horrible après les bombardements de tram
à tort ce qu'ils ont fait au moins 35
morts on écoute le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky
les gens se pressent ils attendent des
trains pour être évacué vers un
territoire sur
ils ont frappé ces gens
il y a des témoins il y à des vidéos il
y à des restes de missiles et des morts
environ 30 morts et des dizaines de
blessés après cette frappe
voilà comment la russie est venu
protéger le dombass voilà sa vision de
la protection des populations
russophones
monod d'art ou est ce qu'on en sait plus
maintenant sur cette attaque de la garde
tram à tort sqbb a écouté pas tellement
plus ça on sait qu'il ya eu une attaque
des roquettes qui sont tombées donc sur
cette gare qui se situe à l'est de
l'ukraine emplettes le voir sur la carte
on sait que cramatte or ce que fera
partie en tout cas des prochaines cibles
dans l'offensive assez massive que veut
lancer l'armée russe pour augmenter son
emprise sur l'est de l'ukraine donc il
ya eu ces tirs de roquettes
le ministère russe de la défense dit que
les troupes russes n'y sont absolument
pour rien ça c'est la version russe et
vous n entendrez volodymyr cnce qui lui
accuse l'armée russe est dit que en fait
il n'y avait pas de soldats ukrainien à
ce très important ça veut dire que ça a
été une frappe délibérée contre une
population composée uniquement de civils
voilà qui ne va pas redorer le blason de
la russie qui est déjà sérieusement
écornée après ce qui s'est passé à bout
de chats et puis maintenant ça c'est au
tour de kiev et puis maintenant ce qu'on
apprend concernant une autre ville
autour de kiev à borodianka toujours est
il que rammaert or ce qu'on voit là les
gens essayer de prendre le train pour
fuir vers l'ouest et que donc il ya eu 7
cette attaque apparemment sans présence
donc militaire ukrainienne mais on voit
que l'objectif c'est le nouvel objectif
de l'armée russe qui a été mise en échec
du côté de kiev c'est de faire depuis
kharkiv qu'on voit pas là qui la
deuxième ville du pays une espèce de
continuité de prendre tout le dôme basse
et puis évidemment marioupol où ça
résiste encore quand même et d' assurer
cette continuité jusqu'à nikolaïev voire
même au dessin qui n'apparaît pas là
alors par ailleurs la présidente de la
commission européenne en cela fondèrent
la hyène accompagné par le chef de la
diplomatie jovette josep borrell sont
attendus aujourd'hui à kiev ils doivent
d'ailleurs s'entretient avec le présent
écrit l'oeuvre du marin c'est lenski sa
marque bien le soutien politique de
l'europe à l'ukraine mais au delà quels
sont les objectifs
écoutez le soutien politique et
symbolique vu la situation que connaît
l'ukraine c'est quand même important on
soit parce que d'abord ça veut dire que
et bien des des dirigeants peuvent
continuer à se rendre à pied ça veut
dire que l'état ukrainien continue à
avoir une vie diplomatique non pas
normal bien sûr mais qui existe qui est
là que donc l'état ukrainien n'est pas
terminée donc c'est le premier
signal envoyé par les deux dirigeants
européens on annonce d'ailleurs
peut-être et sera encore symboliquement
plus fort une visite prochaine du pape
françois l'a évidemment le symbole
serait évidemment énorme donc il ya ce
soutien symbolique politique et puis des
annonces quand même hein donc vous en
avez donné certaines la confirmation que
donc le le charbon russe va être frappé
à partir du mois d'août bon alors après
la question c on sait très bien ce
qu'ils feraient très très mal à la
russie c'est le pétrole et surtout
surtout le gaz mais là c'est compliqué
pour toutes les raisons qu'on explique
régulièrement à cause de la dépendance
énergétique et puis il ya quand même une
annonce parce que visiblement là je sais
pas s'ils sont déjà arrivés à kiev ou
s'ils viennent d'y arriver ou s'ils
l'ont fait ces déclarations avant mais
je sors sur la faune dans l'aisne usaa
borel en fait il annonce quand même que
la candidature de l'ukraine à l'union
européenne va être examinée beaucoup
plus rapidement que d'habitude et que
dès cet été le conseil européen pourrait
examiner la candidature de l'ukraine à
l'union européenne donc ça aussi ça fait
partie du message vous faites partie
alors qu'on se lave essuyé un refus sur
cette proposition de commission à
accélérer 11 de la fin de la vienne a
essuyé un refus sur cette procédure
accélérée un processus à dax où il s'est
présenté au conseil repris mais déjà le
fait que ce soit présenté beaucoup plus
rapidement au conseil européen alors
effectivement après faut que les 27
chefs d'état et de gouvernement du
conseil se mettent d'accord mais en tout
cas ce que ses deux dirigeants la ès
qualité quand même vienne délivrer c'est
votre chemin pour le futur pour l'avenir
il est en europe